oh hello grace helbig here you might
remember this look from such videos as
one you recently watched hi guys it is
August which means school school is
either happening to you or about to
happen to you isn't that exciting it's
like when you're a prepubescent girl and
they tell you that you're either
bleeding from your vagina or you're
about to bleed from your vagina so get
ready
you don't have a choice and that's what
makes it fun school is upon us and tons
of beauty gurus on YouTube are already
are they're probably doing Halloween
videos this that I'm late to the game
one of the major things in high school
that can make or break you other than
your own insecurities which might lead
you to being more sexually open than you
had anticipated for yourself at that age
in your life is backpacks the backpack
that you carry is a message to the rest
of the world about who you are and what
you're about today I'm going to show you
three DIYs that you can do to any
generic plain backpack let's get into it
every beauty guru I feel like has like a
thing like that they do so let's get
into it so I got these three plain
colored backpacks off with Amazon I
think they were under $20 each and today
I'm going to show you how you can take
three extremely generic backpacks and
make them look different I'm gonna start
with our red backpack I'm gonna stuff
the red back package [ __ ]
so it feels bloated now we can really
see the full service area that working
with so maybe you have a backpack and
you don't like the color or the pattern
or whatever is currently on it either
way you can change it by gluing new
fabric on at one point in my adult life
a ton of this brown furry fabric good
aspirations of making a full bodied bear
costume that can work out however
today's your day I'm going to cover this
red backpack in this brown furry fabric
it just requires this next part which is
figuring out how to get the right size
of all of it on there oh so I'm going to
just start randomly tracing and cutting
and gluing
these are terrible scissors these are
literally the worst scissors
get yourself pair of scissors that can
do both by both I mean one thing
yourself pair scissors that can actually
cut oh my god
I gotta find different scissors I'm
sorry we're back with scissors that are
scissors oh these are very dull scissors
okay then we're going to take our glue
gun and glue our fabric just directly on
our backpack oh how cute you can do
different sections of your backpack if
you want but I'm gonna do all of it here
we go out ah uh-huh and doesn't really
matter if the bottom looks good because
no one looks at the ass of your backpack
they look at what's below that backpack
ass your actual ass ah yes I'm alive I'm
alive and I feel things
oh wow oh I get it Wow every turn you
see just my new backpack
you totally stop here but I have bigger
plans for this fur cover backpack I went
on Amazon and I ordered a stuffed teddy
bear I'm gonna use it for this backpack
first thing I'm gonna do is cut its head
off
the second thing I'm gonna do is I have
a bunch of this red foam sticky paper
stuff that I'm going to stick on
underneath this bears mouth as if it has
blood dripping down from its mouth see
cute and I'm gonna take a couple extra
little bits of this red sticky paper and
glue it all around the backpack so it
looks like blood is everywhere okay
we've gotta get our blood splatters all
over the place and now we're going to do
is finish with our bear now I'm going to
take these arms legs and head and glue
them onto the backpack turns out gluing
fur fabric onto fur fabric sucks a huge
dick that's that it uh the bear from
revenant
we got now every time you put this
backpack on you can feel just like
Leonardo DiCaprio high school feels like
you're getting mauled by a bear every
day anyway so why not
Chris terrified
hey guys what's next algebra hummock
unbearable hey guys I know I'm want to
go to the mall hey guys have you got up
on the Olympics yeah that's some intense
athleticism down in the Caprio Brazil
now on tour put our black backpack
I think this backpack looks really cool
on its own without any modifications at
all but that's not the point of this
video so we're going to change it I saw
a bunch of really cool backpacks on
Pinterest that were just like really
abstract shapes so I thought that I
would add some shapes to this and see if
I could make it abstract let's see how
this works out I'm going to keep this
monochromatic so I found these pants in
my drawer that I had originally bought
to go to Finland and wear them there and
I did it now I'm going to cut this up
and use it to make this backpack cool
I'm going to just make like a couple big
circles I think I'm gonna freeball it
let's do
why don't I just buy adult scissors I
got some abstract shapes that I cut out
I'm gonna glue gun around the edges and
stuff them with stuffing like I'm making
two little pillows it's a sort of learn
from Lara DIYs that you don't actually
sew anything ever they're in a glue
almost the whole opening sketch we got
to leave a little bit of an opening so
when we turn it inside out with stuff
it's stuffing a pillow now we're going
to turn them inside out
and then we're gonna stuff them like
pillows look close okay now I thought
it'd be fun to add some spice on to
these shapes I found some of this in my
closet oh [ __ ] do this let's do it bro
swag I don't use hardly at all film is
gonna it's the same color that is just
glue some of this weird [ __ ] all over
the place
cool all right you have shark shapes
have lots of texture let's add them to
our backpack isn't not gonna stick I did
not plan this correctly safety pins if
you got them this fabric is a great job
of not being penetrable by any sort of
safety pin this fabric well okay okay
and there we have our totally abstract
yeah my backpack maybe it needs
something alright uh-huh look at that
abstract backpack okay oh God now onto
our white backpack this backpack you can
do just about anything with I'm going to
show you how you can take fabric markers
and iron-on letters and totally
transform a very normal white backpack
maybe some markers from fabric markers
I'm just gonna kind of like to stress
the backpack a little bit in one book
greyish antique ish vibe
want this to go faster we figure this
out I have some gray paint so I'm just
gonna see what happens with this not
what I oh okay now what I thought I
might do but you can do whatever you
want
super fun it doesn't have to be perfect
like motto okay so I like the texture
that's been created on this backpack I'm
gonna add some accents oh this paint
should be dry we're gonna come back to
this backpack see if this is dried all
right it is now the next day and my gray
paint textured backpack has dried I
really like the way it looks so now what
I was trying to do yesterday which was
unsuccessful is take a black fabric
marker and just draw some accents next
fun little details now I'm going to iron
out some letters fun phrase oh I'm ready
hey buddy
oh I finally iron own on my letters and
peeled off all of their backings and it
was a struggle but let me show you the
final outcome tada
Greg Behrendt chic come on
oh my god
Ashley your drift was so funny I died oh
my god did you see the Jonathan Taylor -
mama retweeted me I'm dead oh my god I
love lunch so much those tater tots were
so good buried me in them there you go
there are my three backpack DIYs for
back-to-school I hope this helped you
you don't have to make backpacks exactly
the way that I did make them
individualized to you and um good luck
high school sucks enough you don't
happen to by that I mean you don't SMU
geez don't s any DS just take your SATs
I don't know now you don't want to carry
just a standard JanSport backpack that
you buy online because you hate going to
stores and interacting with people
because you think that they sell the
photos of you with that dude that happen
based on your own insecurities and you
forgot about the idea that like
documentation is such a rampant rabid
thing in your age group and no matter
how good you are in your soul you can't
stop people from wanting to shame you so
that they feel slightly better because
they haven't truly experience life and
all it has to offer they're just trying
to be a top dog and a small race what
whoa sorry your promposal sucked but